you
it's my very great pleasure today to
welcome today's view from the top
speaker Ted Turner it's difficult to
know where to begin
when introducing someone like Ted Turner
because he has made an impact in so many
different areas he's primarily known in
the business world for his impact on the
media which began when he took over a
billboard advertising business when he
was 24 years old he used profits from
this enterprise to enter cable
television just as it was beginning to
take hold in the u.s. in what was an
audacious move at the time he launched a
24-hour cable news network in 1980 CNN
was the first all news TV network in the
u.s. at the time many questioned how
anybody could fill the airwaves with
news content continuously today it is
difficult to imagine what news and
politics was like before 24-hour
coverage existed after launching CNN Ted
began buying media content including the
film studio MGM and used the library to
create multiple successful cable
franchises including TNT and Turner
Classic Movies the resulting Turner
Broadcasting systems
eventually merged with Time Warner in
1996
mr. Turner was vice chairman of Time
Warner and its largest stockholder when
the company merged with AOL in 2000 in
what I'm sure mr. Turner would agree
with perfect hindsight was probably not
optimal timing but in many respects
Teddy's not here to talk about business
at all he's on campus to attend a
meeting of the United Nations Foundation
where he is chair of the board the UN
foundation was established with Ted's
pledge of 1 billion dollars in 1998 the
largest philanthropic gift of its time
the foundation was established to
strengthen and support the UN and its
causes through a blend of advocacy grant
making and partnerships these causes
include children's health climate and
energy sustainable development women and
population initiatives
ted is also an outspoken
environmentalist and as the largest
landowner in the United States with more
than two million acres of land an area
larger than the states of Delaware and
Rhode Island combined his decision to
focus on ecological sustainability in
land management has already had a major
impact
Teddy's owner of the Atlanta Braves
baseball team and Atlanta Hawks
basketball team not content to just
stand on the sidelines however he also
was skipper of a winning America's Cup
sailing team in 1977 he's known to be
outspoken and controversial earning him
the nickname the mouth from the south
but he has also been named other things
such as Man of the Year by Time magazine
and humanist of the Year by the American
Humanist Association while this is only
a partial list of accomplishments one
theme that ought to be abundantly clear
is that when Ted Turner does something
he does not do it neatly it should make
for an interesting discussion today Ted
is going to be interviewed by Jason Lee
Kenan one of our second-year student
leaders of the speaker series before
opening the discussion to QA Jason also
has a record in the media business
having worked for Hulu during the summer
and for Disney prior to business school
as well as goldman sachs and takes a
specific group I'm not sure how Jason is
assailing but he's an impressive
classical pianist please join me today
in welcoming Ted Turner to the Stanford
Graduate School of Business
good afternoon everyone and thank you
again mr. Turner for coming to it with
us today sorry I'll call you Ted that is
the name of your book right right so I
thought I'd start off by asking you a
question on entrepreneurship as you
probably know Stanford is well known for
inspiring entrepreneurship amongst its
students and I'm sure many of the
students in the audience today one day
would like to start their own company as
the founder of many companies including
CNN TBS Ted's Montana grill and turnover
renewable energy could you talk to us a
little bit about the challenges you
faced and starting new businesses it's a
lot of work it's a lot of work and
you've got to have a a good concept of
what you want to do and and you need to
have some knowledge of how to obtain
capital because almost any business of
any size requires capital and then I
hate to say it but you can't you can't
do it in in just a couple of lines when
I get asked that question though when I
get asked it groups like this I say you
know the secret of success in business
is early to bed early to rise work like
hell and advertise
that's about as good as there's anything
but but but I would recommend because in
a book you can cover it better that's
why I wrote the book that sounds like
advertising and also I don't have to say
the same the same damn thing over and
over again you know
so let me other things we did a lot in
television we had a lot of reruns and
when you get over 70 life just turns
into one big rewrite so you've found to
these companies over a period of thirty
years have the leadership challenges in
50 years have the leadership challenge
has changed over that time ah no not
really
I don't think still pretty much the same
thing don't forget to advertise
shifting gears then for a Saturday so in
1998 you founded the UN foundation with
an historic 1 billion dollar donation
what motivated you to make this donation
and why the United Nation UN was in a
lot of trouble they were in financial
trouble and this was back before
governments bailed out companies this
was the time when companies and
individuals bailed out governments and
at the u.s. the United States was over a
billion dollars in arrears on their dues
to the UN and the UN couldn't pay their
peacekeepers we're the biggest
contributor and we were almost two years
behind in our payments and I it drove me
crazy because I I am a student of
history and I read a lot when I was
younger studied history very very
carefully and I don't think we'd be here
today without the United Nations I think
the United Nations did for all the
things that they didn't do and it's not
perfect like our federal government's
not perfect like state governments not
perfect but but it did maybe it was luck
but we did prevent World War three and
if we had had a World War three
particularly about the time of the Cuban
Missile Crisis which was the closest we
came we'd probably all be dead and
that's worth saving you know something
that saves everybody is worth hanging on
to and I was trying to figure out how I
could get the money to the UN because
all of a sudden I had been worth I was
worth a couple billion dollars and it
happened real quickly my stock went up
when CNN turned the corner in a period
of just a few years I went from just
about broke to worth well at the high
point close to ten billion and so I had
I had the money and I the first thing I
thought is why don't I go to the UN and
buy the debt at a discount
you know offered at business school
right at 20
was and and and then I could I could
present the bill to be paid the UN
couldn't push the United States because
they wanted to stay a member that they
had to be real nice even though if you
owe somebody a lot of money you're
supposed to be nice to him anyway that's
what we got forget about China we've got
to be nice to China because we Alma
trillion dollars an idea how we could
get rid of that - real quickly yes so
you know China wants to build an
aircraft carrier because they'd like to
they've got a lot of money now and they
don't know what to do with some of it
aircraft carriers aren't much help at a
place like Afghanistan and we've got I
don't know what twelve battlegroups
and we all China trillion dollars why
don't we sit down with him and say look
you guys want aircraft carriers we can't
use them in Afghanistan and Iraq and all
the wars were fighting they weren't very
helpful in Vietnam either we'll sell you
we'll give you our aircraft carriers if
you write off the debt and then you can
have a specific fleet you know what you
gonna do with it right I really think
Wars totally obsolete that's but anyway
I was going to buy I was going to buy
the debt and then sue the United States
for the full-face amount
pick up a couple hundred million dollars
saw on the deal and I check with my
lawyers and they said you can't do that
an individual can't bring the lawsuit
against the United States
for paid unpaid bills so I that that
didn't work and it took me took me a
while but I kept thinking I when I its
like CNN I I spent three years just
thinking about it
before I even started it I was just
amazed at CBS NBC R or it CBS didn't
didn't do it because they had all the
infrastructure at a news department they
had the bureaus all they would had to do
was was do it but they didn't have the
imagination and that's another good
thing to do is go into a business where
the people that are running it are a
bunch of dumb asses that makes it easy
to have dumb competitors is one of the
best ways to get started so when you
think about the UN foundation today what
are the most critical issues that it's
working on and what are you most proud
of in terms of what they've accomplished
so far well the thing that that we're
working on the most is trying to
eradicate the intractable diseases that
we were there not intractable because
they were and and we've done it with
partnerships with gates with rotary for
instance with polio we are maybe one
year away thanks to some breaks that we
got from eradicating polio and that will
only be the second disease in the
history of the world that's ever been
eradicated smallpox being the other one
that will be a gigantic win for those of
you that are sports fans so it's just
about everybody you know it's like we
need a W humanity needs a W well last
week somebody blew up refugees were
standing in line to get a little food in
bowls and somebody killed 35 of them
what the hell are you bombing refugees
for I mean what does that accomplish you
what are they a different religion with
what in the name of God are we doing why
don't we start acting like civilized
educated decent kind-hearted human
beings that's what why don't we start
doing that it's not that hard
I spent my whole life doing it and it's
been a ball so you've spoken many people
like to help other people like in Haiti
I mean we spent a million dollars the
first day you know and billions and
millions of dollars most people want to
help other people who in this room would
like to bomb somebody not one person how
many people want to help other people
yeah that's right that's that's humanity
that's that why don't we start acting
like human beings one of the topics
you've spoken out a lot about and I
think you were most passionate about is
climate change poses a real threat to us
so if you were running this country what
are the three things you would do to
help combat this issue
well why three okay how about that's
like my competitors at CBS ABC at ABC
they only thought of three but I thought
of ten ways to attack them and maybe
they stopped me on the first three but I
got up with the other seven you didn't
answer the question though so what would
you do because it was such a dumb
question
actually why well one I to ask people to
turn out the lights you know that
basically all the the cheapest and and
and quickest way to make progress is to
is to conserve stead serve energy walk
don't drive and you know so that that
sort of thing and then what we have to
do is switch over to it's time to say
goodbye to coal and oil and replace them
with renewable energy but solar when
possibly geothermal if we can figure
figure out how to do it we should be
doing a lot of research on it because it
has tremendous potential and it's time
to the Industrial Revolution was started
with burning coal it's time time to say
goodbye to it we're burning too much of
it and it's up at its poisonous and
we're going to we're going to run out of
it anyway but but it's time to say
goodbye to coal and I mean say goodbye
to cold to those 35 senators from the
coal states they're going to vote for
coal they don't care what happens they
do have care what happens to the country
but they care more about whether they
get reelected than anything else but
we're gonna have to get our government
to work better and because that then
they have to be able to do more than one
thing at a time I mean I ran CNN and the
Cartoon Network at the same time and we
have to multitask I mean they just
stopped the whole country comes to a
halt for six months while they get to
get the health care bill through why
can't they do two or three bills at one
time you know I mean you take more than
one course don't you
right sake I'm you know we gotta get
with the program
so you made things up a bit going to
high gear I like that see you mentioned
China before and I think one of the big
challenges with addressing climate
change is it's really a global issue and
countries like China and India are
projected to be the biggest producers of
carbon emissions of the next decade
yellow China it's very very close to it
right now
so what should the u.s. be doing to
figure out the global dynamics here
basically there's a lot of people
thinking of it thinking about it then
and working on it I'm I am and it's we
get we just got it we got to keep with
it we can't really afford to lose this
one and it's not just climate change
climate change is a symptom of
overpopulation and too many people using
too much stuff if we what we have to do
is we've got to stabilize the population
and and and and and quickly because we
can't handle nine billion people would
6.7 billion when I was born in 1938
there were only 2 billion people in the
world in in in the lifetime of one
person in those 70 years we've increased
the number of people on the planet by 3
and a half times that's that's gigantic
nothing like that ever ever happened for
if we'd have had that many more
elephants for Christ's sake we'd all be
elephant dung you know I think so we've
got to whoa we've got to go what we
really need to do and Paul Ehrlich I
know he's around but he's involved here
I think I I read the Population Bomb 30
years ago and he feels like that because
I talked to him I had him out for a
weekend 30 years ago when I was doing my
research on population and he thought
that the world population ought to be
between two and two and a half billion
people that with that we could support
job you know internal combustion engines
there wouldn't be so many people that
would overwhelm the
the resource basically the planets
collapsing all around us the ocean
fisheries are collapsing from
overfishing there's the topsoil that the
topsoil is eroding away from farming the
kind of farming that we do what we plow
and and wind and water erosion or
washing the washing the topsoil away
we've got to take better care of the
planet because without without a healthy
environment it's the population is not
going to make it and with the end with
that 6.7 billion population there's a
billion people going to bed hungry
tonight we're going to do if we had two
or three billion more people and that's
where we're headed if we keep Bob going
the way that we're that we're going so
we have to do that first because that's
the most important thing and and or we
have to do it simultaneous so we're
gonna have to multitask we're gonna have
to stop doing the dumb things and start
doing the smart things that we got to
start with you your generation has got
to be the one that does it because if
you wait till another generation before
you start turning things around
it's going to be too late so and and and
global warming or climate change it's
just all one symptom of a sick planet
because of too many people using too
much stuff going back to business for a
second over the last 10 years this
business has gotten a bad rap from Enron
to the recent financial crisis a lot of
it was deserved
obviously business leaders are more
vilified and glorified what do you think
the reason is for that and what can we
do instead of been vilified you know
just like God the good guys ought to be
lionized
like me I never did anything wrong I not
anything substantially wrong
not that I got caught well I would have
gotten caught too because I was
high-profile enough and they were enough
people would have liked it
we've got to play by the rules you've
got to it's not that hard you could you
can make billions doing it playing by
the rules and doing it honestly if
you're smart enough and work hard enough
so I'm the topic of the financial crisis
reportedly in 2007 you transferred
almost all of your financial portfolio
to cash successfully in fighting the
crisis right okay or bonds but that's
that wasn't the reason that did it so I
wasn't asking you I had dollars I had
lost between seven and eight billion on
the AOL transaction and gone from eight
or nine billion and for a brief moment I
think the high I went over ten and I was
back down to under two and I was just
and that was in Time Warner I thought
you know I I was like cashing in my
chips when I merged with Time Warner and
and and and but but I lost so much it's
that back but a óli it was just hard to
believe that we could make so many
mistakes it was really just one merging
with them without doing adequate due
diligence and finding out that the books
were cooked and we didn't know it not a
church didn't catch it but of course we
only did one day of due diligence anyway
yeah it's on a forty billion dollar deal
or 100 billion dollar deal depending on
what's your gross enough so III just
wanted to hang on because there's
nothing worse than being a broke old man
who once was rich
and I want to be able to have enough
money to cover my funeral without having
to have my children
cough it up do you think there are steps
we should have taken to prevent the
financial crisis yeah we should not have
borrowed so much money I don't know a
penny to a soul and haven't for a long
time I think I think you ought to aim in
your business career and in your life to
be out of debt by the time they're 60
and not owe anything on your house or
anything else say and the reason for
that is because after 60 it's hard to
find a job people don't want you because
of medical care you know you've got
people older people have more health
problems than younger people and so boy
it's really hard hard to find a job over
60 unless you want to be a greeter at
Walmart you know it's so I know because
I haven't had a job in over 10 years
that's one reason I had to start these
philanthropies and I did have some kind
of activity so if I don't have it coming
in at least I can have it going out
movement you know just don't stand still
do something
are there any CEOs or business leaders
today that you admire yeah I like Warren
Buffett and I like I like Bill Gates
I like the winners they end it there's
some other ones so I guess you know
looking back you founded a media empire
became a billionaire started a
restaurant chain won the World Series
won the World Series that was important
invested in renewable energy married a
movie star for those people in the
audience who aspire to do something like
that do you have any advice to us going
out to the work
pump a lot of iron it's tiring but I
really had a great time I've had a great
life and I'm having a great life right
now
well before we turn it over to the
audience here for some questions in 2008
you celebrated your 70th birthday with a
party in Atlanta and reportedly you
spent some time reading poetry to the
guests you know I did not I I quoted it
from memory even better
so you said at the time that the words
that have meant the most to you on
integrity or from Shakespeare would you
like to share some of that with us I
think it's Richard the third it's short
it's the best lines on integrity that
I've ever that I've ever heard my honor
is my life we live in one take honor
from me and my life is done then pray my
liege my honor let me try for that I
live and for that will I die thank you
very much
I'm gonna give you the other two that I
gave up my birthday to the the lines
that on courage because if you're gonna
be successful in business you got to
have a lot of courage then step forward
Horatius this is from Horatius at the
bridge by Thomas Macaulay then step
forward to raciest the captain of the
gate he said to every man of woman born
death cometh soon or late and how can
man die better than facing fearful odds
for the ashes of his father's and the
temples of his gods hew down the bridge
sir counseled with all the speedy Bay I
would but to beside me will hold the
phone and play on your narrow span a
thousand might well be stopped by three
now who will stand on either hand and
guard the bridge with me pretty strong
they stopped the holy trust in our
and the last one is the longest one and
I'm really hope I don't forget a line in
it but love you and it's also from
Richard the third and it's about
humility no matter where of comfort no
man's speak let's talk of worms of
graves and epitaphs make dust our paper
and with rainy eyes write sorrow on the
bosom of Earth let's choose executives
and talk of wills and yet not so for
what can we bequeath save our deposed
bodies to the ground our lands our lives
and all our Bolingbroke's and nothing
can we call our own save death and that
small model of the barren earth that
serves as paste and cover to our bones
for God's sake let us sit upon the
ground and tell sad stories of the death
of kings how some had been deposed some
slain in war some haunted by the ghosts
they have the pole to pose some poisoned
by their wives some sleeping killed all
murdered forth in the hollow crown that
rounds the mortal temples of a king
keeps death his watch there the annexes
scoffing at his state and grinning at
his pomp infusing him with self and vain
conceit as if this flesh which walls
about our life were brass impregnable
and comes out the last and with a little
pin bores through his castle wall and
farewell king cover your heads and mock
not flesh and blood with solemn
reverence throw away respect tradition
form and ceremonious duty I live with
bread like you feel want taste grief
need friends subjected to us how can you
say to me I am a king
my company in 1970 the first year in the
television business there were 35
employees and we did $600,000 in lost
nine hundred thousand almost a million
that same exact company 30 years later
did 2.5 billion had 12,000 employees and
made 600 million I would see our merged
with Time Warner that that's what you
could do is just say smoke them the
stock went up two thousand four one
during that time and that's how you make
them you want to be a billionaire start
with nothing and turned it into a
fortune so that now that we'd like to
open it up to questions from the
audience please take a mic and make sure
to stand up sorry thanks very much for
coming today one to ask you a question
about mentorship I'm wondering who have
been some of your biggest mentors over
your career and what are some of the
biggest lessons you've learned from them
my father was definitely the biggest one
he taught me about business it was saw
he was in the billboard business and it
was a real easy business you leased the
space put up a sign and then rented it
to advertiser for enough to have a
profit
but I wanted to do more with my life and
just make money so I wanted to get into
television where I could do programming
I wondered I had ideas for four programs
and so that's what I well but he was he
taught me about how to you know that
what profits and losses were and so
forth mr Turner Ted thank you for
joining Ted thank you for joining us
today during this conversation we talked
about both your experience as an
entrepreneur fighting against the odds
and also for your passion about the
environment a lot of the challenges that
even people here at Stanford have
characterized our global ecosystem I was
wondering if you could think of
so bringing those two together and speak
to one to what extent what advice you
have for business leaders who want to
have an impact in those issues and - do
you have any specific other any specific
opportunities that excite you outside of
energy whether it be water or soil
agriculture etc well I think of I think
of soil and and water and energy
together but but I think that's that's
where I would if I was starting in
business today that's that's where I'd
go because we've got to completely
rebuild our whole energy system all over
the world we've got to phase out coal
and and oil we go along with boone
pickens that we ought to use natural gas
as a bridge fuel to when we are when
we're completely reliant on on solar
wind and and perhaps some geothermal and
and bio biofuels that that's where I go
I think that's where the growth
industries for the for the for the
future are at least for the immediate
future for the next 3040 years
and I mean I'm personally going there
myself I we're building one of the
largest solar installations in New
Mexico with I partnered with a Southern
Company which is the big utility the
biggest one in the southeast one of the
biggest ones in the country and their
half of their power is generated from
coal and but not what I'm doing is I'm
partnering up with them and trying to
work with them and to show them that we
can go that they can go with clean
energy rather than fight them but but
I've been known to do a little fighting
too from time to time yes sir thanks ed
for coming
Steven van helden I'm a first year
students here at the GSB so a lot of the
business ideas that you've spoken about
have being you know business ideas with
a social mission meteor in itself is
effectively a business idea is a
business that does have a large social
mission and I think that is around
education I wonder if you could talk a
little bit about getting the right
trade-off between propaganda and
education and how much mass appeal you
get versus you know a smaller smaller
audience and how are you at you know and
CNN broadly have kind of struggled with
that well not necessarily you struggled
with that but how you found that that
sort of trade-off I'm I asked because
I'm hard of hearing they were about
three or four questions there that's
very complex I mean it takes a bias
that's a good question and you have to
as far as as far as just take the news
media take the news network take CNN
they're being beaten in the ratings by
Fox with Shaw I knew that that was where
the greatest threat to CNN would come
from we didn't come from a right-wing
Network this was before I even started
CNN that there because and and they have
done a good job of filling that niche on
the one hand you could say that they're
not as responsible as I would like to
see them see them be but they're very
successful and and sometimes doing the
wrong thing is more successful than do
the right thing and that's one of the
hardest things about business I I I
couldn't do the wrong thing and make
money on it III just I had too much
pride to do that I'd rather not be
successful and be successful by doing
the wrong thing and for me it worked
luckily it doesn't work for everybody it
it's it's a very hard thing to wall to
balance it really is and that and that
you know it's one thing just to go into
business to make some money
but most people have enough trouble
that's hard to do by itself and then if
you have a strong sense of social
consciousness on top of that that's just
as another layer of complexity to it but
I would strongly recommend because I did
it and was successful that way that that
you go strive that way to do it with a
with a conscious is what you do is
something you can be proud of and
because I think in the long run that's
really more important that you have your
pride and that you did good with your
life rather than just making a lot of
money but it's not easy hi Ted my name
is Erica Sonia I grew up watching
Captain Planet and wanted to thank you
for that of all the things I did I'm
really proud of Captain Planet how many
how many people in the room grew up on
Captain Planet look around if we save
this world it's going to be partially
because of Captain no I'm serious
that's right because Captain Planet
taught you about environmental
stewardship didn't it I mean I came up
with the idea that I said whose ID the
Cartoon Network outside there I had
already bought Tom and Jerry Bugs Bunny
I mean I had everything I had the
Flintstones I had I had I had the
Jetsons I had all I had I mean I was the
cartoon King and then I bought all the
movies that Gone with the Wind Citizen
Kane I just it was so great oh what fun
anyway but Captain Planet I the girls
and the boys in it were both the same
you know they the girls were just as
smart as the guys yep and and there were
kids from all over the world Kwame from
Africa right wheeler from New York
gee from Asia she was composite asian
girl linka from the soviet union and we
had to change it to rush it because
Soviet Union disappeared while Captain
Planet was running it ran all over the
world including Russia including China
and they won't run it I if I could do
one thing at Time Warner did get Captain
Planet back on the Cartoon Network at a
decent time so we can train today's kids
because it's the stories are still you
know they're timeless
so as you mentioned earlier there's a
lot of energy effort being expended to
deal with the symptoms of environmental
problems and of the two point four
trillion dollars that our federal
government collects in taxes ninety-five
percent of that comes from taxing wealth
innovation labor and less than five
percent of that comes from taxing
activities that generate negative
externalities pollution resource
depletion waste and efficiency so to my
question what do you see as like as the
best way to actually address the root
cause of environmental problems instead
of just dealing with the symptoms I know
you mentioned earlier population control
you have any other ideas in control
family plan parents don't like to be
controlled but they like the plan
alright it's very important that's why I
i forbade the the TV announcers on CNN
to use the word farm because what CNN
was going all over the world it looked
really stupid foreign who's far
everybody was close together now because
we've interconnected the whole world so
but what's what's the question so what
do you use is a long how what are some
ways in which we can deal with the root
cause of environmental problems what do
you see as the most effective ways
should we be taxing food absolutely
tax the polluters you bet and then
rebate absolutely that's who should be
paying for it
that's who you know why should we be
paying for somebody else's pollution
that's not the solution what do you see
us the role of education versus
technology
gastly you know and he was also have
some do you see an education playing a
role in this as well of course
everything plays the role it's Captain
Planet was television but that was
educational television right
sure education is extremely important if
we don't have a good educational system
that teaches Germany had a great
educational system in 1935 the only
problem was it was preaching hatred you
know I mean they were saying that the
educational system was anti-semitic
there but but we need an education
system that's strongly educators about
the environment and how important it is
to preserve it you bet it's not just
something that we just can can rape and
pillage and and and and and expect it to
support us I want to see us sustainable
I'd like to see what's wrong with the
concept of where 5,000 years from now
people are still here living in harmony
with nature right and having a great
life
well I think what we've done one of the
biggest mistakes we've made in America
and in the Western world to a smaller
degree but there America is is we've
emphasized that how much money you have
and how much you spend is what
determines how happy you are that's not
right the thing that really determines
your happiness is your relationships
with your family with your friends and
and we need to have we need to change
over that's what got us in all this
financial problem people wanted to spend
more money so they barb went out and
borrowed more than their house was worth
against their house the bank's learned
the money that was the bank's mistake we
were all but it's our fault that we got
it in this problem it basically was
because we were spending more they had
George Soros figured it out I think six
percent a year four five the last five
years we spent more than then we were
earning and borrowing the money for the
Chinese it can't operate like that what
we should do is them in smaller houses
or building smaller houses now smaller
houses and smaller automobiles I Drive a
Prius that's my main car you know I'm a
billionaire still and and I don't have a
gigantic house I got a nice house I'll
tell you but it
but it's not gigantic I mean you know I
don't feel guilty about living there and
and and and and put more emphasis get to
know your next-door neighbors don't
drive all the way across town but get to
know the people next door again play
bridge with them you know it doesn't
cost anything for Christ's sake you know
cook dinner together yeah more fun than
you do if you go out and drink too much
at some fancy restaurant anyway and I'm
in the restaurant business so please go
out to the moderately priced wrestling
like Ted's Montana grill we're not in
California anyway is that answer the
question that's you guys are asking you
guys and girls are asking tough
questions hi is Washington another first
year MBA student here you mentioned
earlier that government should work
better and I wondered how you think the
24 hour news cycle either helps or
perhaps hinders governments from working
as well as they should be
well it depends on how it's how it's
used if it's used to turn people against
the government
it's got my concept of the way I tried
to run CNN was to tell the truth in an
on nom a non-threatening non-threatening
way and to whenever there were
controversial issues to seek out the
leading proponents of both sides and let
let them air their opinions didn't let
the viewers make up their own own minds
some of this talk radio now tries to
make up your mind for you and to
convince you that they're right you know
and their right-wing or whatever or
left-wing but but that's the way the way
I tried to do it it's very complicated
it's these are not table your your would
expect Stanford Business School
postgraduate you'd expect good questions
and and we're getting them their most
complicated questions that that you
could ask but that's okay I just wish I
could answer them better but the answers
can't be simple they have to be calm
they're there
complex by their very nature complex
answers to complex questions hi Ted
David Everage team here and I'm a second
year MBA candidate this one might be a
little bit easier but Malcolm Gladwell
recently profiled you as an entrepreneur
and you kind of touched on this a little
bit earlier in terms of he profile
entrepreneurs is not being risk takers
but rather calculating opportunistic
predators I'd like to get you your your
view on that and your do you agree with
him or how you be yourself into Malcolm
Gladwell he said he say well the the
thrust of the article was he's a Harvard
psychologist Oh in a New York Times and
New Yorker columnist the so the the
thrust of the of the piece was about
entrepreneurs as being more calculating
predators as opposed to risk takers how
we commonly view them so bad I can't
remember I can't remember whether I got
Parkinson's or Alzheimer's so I guess my
question so like that's it original so I
guess
the the the thrust of the question I'm
sorry I'm not being clear do you view
yourself as a risk-taker or in terms of
risky coming here thank you
I'm lucky to be here
view any more questions yeah I said Alex
on hand first year MBA you came into
television at a time of large transition
and I think a lot of people would say
that the television industry is changing
a lot right now too with content being
delivered over the internet and video
on-demand everything like that I was
wondering if you could to speak for a
second on where you see media and the
television industry going in the next
5-10 years or if you have a view on that
I don't know I'm not in the media
business anymore I've moved on to energy
and I'm having enough trouble keeping up
with that you got to keep up with solar
they got a magazine that comes out every
week you got wind got to read that every
week geothermal that is that every week
I say I read The Economist that's my
basic news source because I need to know
what's going on in the world even though
I don't have CN anymore but I with my
work at the UN I have to know everything
that's going on everywhere all the time
and just trying to keep up with where
it's wearing my behind out I got to keep
up with all the environmental stuff I
got a every week I call somebody up over
TBS and try and get them to put Captain
Planet back on
hey I'll tell you what y'all could do
let's see I'm trying to remember who's
the chairman of Time Warner now it
happens that he's actually a GSB alumnus
yeah who is Jeff Bewkes chef bukas why
don't you alright Jeff you kiss a letter
each individually saying I'm a captain
I'm a Planeteer put Captain Planet back
there then we have time for one more
question
dad one I'm a first year MBA from India
just had a question what's your biggest
in your view what's your biggest
accomplishment and your biggest regret
in life biggest regret rate that my
marriages didn't work yes that really is
so I've been married three times and the
biggest accomplishment probably was
Turner Broadcasting and specifically CNN
it was the first global news network was
the first global network and the first
24-hour news saw news source so it was
it was a it was all groundbreaking I
think it's fair to say everyone please
join me in thanking